at the U.S treasury secretary has
appeared before a senate committee
assuring it that the country's banking
system is sound
we worked with the Federal Reserve and
FDIC to protect all depositors of the
two failed Banks
on Monday morning customers were able to
access all of the money in their deposit
accounts so they could make payroll and
pay the bills
shareholders and debt holders are not
being protected by the government
importantly no taxpayer money is being
used or put at risk with this action
deposit protection is provided by the
deposit Insurance Fund which is funded
by fees on banks
Kristin saloumi is in New York so
Kristen Janet Yellen saying the
situation is stable wanting to reassure
everybody lawmakers and the public at
large except now there's another
American Bank that's in trouble
thank you
that's right and that had been weighing
on investors concerns certainly we'd
seen uh concern in the stock markets
about One Bank in particular First
Republic another California Bank that it
was worried was teetering on a banking
failure but good news today word out now
that financial institutions including
Chase Citibank and other major U.S banks
are working on a deal to shore up First
Republic to deposit money there so that
it has the liquidity it needs for its
depositors to calm fears and prevent
what was feared would be a domino effect
of another bank being in trouble
depositors getting nervous going to take
their money out not having the money to
cover those withdrawals and this leading
to Contagion throughout the banking
sector so so this news is certainly
being welcomed as a sign that the crisis
has been contained on top of the
reassurances that we've been hearing
from Janet Yellen the treasury secretary
something else to throw at you Kristen
we're hearing now that is the troubled
European bank is now facing legal action
in the U.S
foreign
this is true uh now Credit Suisse of
course uh word that it was having issues
sent U.S markets tumbling on Tuesday and
even the news of a settlement to shore
up that bank wasn't enough to calm
American investors but that news along
with the first Republic's news seems to
be lifting markets here in the banking
sector as well in the United States uh
the lawsuit that has been filed against
Credit Suisse is on behalf of American
investors who say that the bank was not
disclosing problems that it had that it
made false or misleading statements to
uh and it didn't disclose that it had a
what it called significant outflow
issues in its fourth quarter as well as
material weaknesses and internal
controls so that could once again shake
things for Credit Suisse but so far
we're seeing that its Bank shares that
its value in the market is up with all
the other banking stocks that are up as
a result of the latest news on First
Republic all right thank you Christian
salumi in New York